what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so a superior Ironman really wrapped up
what I wanted to do is fill the next
couple weeks or so who's just a
miscellaneous stories that I've kind of
been kicking around stories that I
thought would be pretty fun to cover and
I want to pick up with something called
schism now schism is basically like this
x-men Civil War right like back in 2011
it was this idea of creating this rift
in the x-men community where you had the
Wolverine side and you had the Cyclops
side and the both the two of them
actually end up fighting but it's really
kind of cool because one of the things
that Marvel was looking at really in the
post house of M era was ways to
basically kind of rework and create new
interest in the x-men franchise back in
2004 during the events of house of M and
really a lot of this stems all the way
back to like project wide awake back in
the 80s and the in the early 90s Marvel
was looking at the idea of basically
reducing the mutant population what they
ended up doing was they had the Scarlet
Witch sort of go crazy strip 98% of the
mutant population of their powers and so
instead of there being millions of
mutants now there were only 198 now the
cool thing about this is because of the
fact that mutant population had been
reduced down to such a small number what
it did is it allowed Marvel to tell more
concise and more character-driven
stories about the x-men really in terms
of the individual characters themselves
and take them in new directions
specifically emphasis was put on Cyclops
and the reason why I say that is because
this story really marks like the
beginning of Marvel turning Cyclops into
not really a villain so much as an
antihero
but at the very least moving him away
from like the Boy Scout role that he
played in Marvel for so long because
Cyclops was always like the number one
guy of Charles Xavier and he was the one
guy who always believed in his dream and
the one guy who would always do whatever
it took to make it happen this does come
out of a couple of things one of the
biggest things that comes out of is
Second Coming remember when it came to
the idea of of house of M the the idea
that mutants had been reduced down to
198 there was a story called
Messiah Complex and that dealt with the
birth of Hope Summers really this
character who's almost completely
irrelevant now but at the time she was
the first mutant born after the events
of house of M and Marvel said okay if
we're gonna have mutants start coming
back it's gonna be a much slower and a
far more gradual process as opposed to
just mutants popping up everywhere and
so what this ended up doing is it led to
Marvel introducing something called the
five
and the five lights were basically just
five mutants basically the five mutants
who were born after the events of house
of M after Hope Summers now in truth it
was really hopes like own little team
there was just generation hope is really
all it was but the reason why this is
important is because with the birth of
Hope Summers there was this mad dash of
people to basically get their hands on
her not only that there was also a guy
by the name of Bastian
now Bastian is kind of this weird
scenario he's basically like a
combination of Nimrod and master mold
now Nimrod is basically a sentinel from
the Days of Future past who travelled
back in time to try to kill the x-men
that kind of a thing but the idea is
that master mold was literally this
giant machine that cranked out sentinels
what ended up happening is master mold
and Nimrod version to a singular being
named Bastion now Bastion had things
like operation zero tolerance and neo so
on and so forth but the overall gist is
that he had always been an enemy of the
x-men eventually during the events of
Second Coming he had launched like wave
after wave after wave against the x-men
this combined with like the purifiers
this crazy religious zealot regroup that
was led by William Stryker basically
resulted in like the destruction of the
Xavier Institute at the same time the
Green Goblin Norman Osborn had seized
control of shield he'd taken over the
United States
the x-men basically bailed out they
moved from Westchester all the way out
to utopia which is an island off the
coast of San Francisco there were a lot
of things that were going on in the
midst of this story being told or at
least things that led up to the story
again I think it'd be kind of cool to
cover that stuff but I don't really know
if people have an interest in it but at
the very least the reason why this
matters is because again the x-men are
at a point where they're beginning to be
accepted to a degree now the other half
of this is that because of the fact that
Cyclops had intervened during the whole
attempt by Bastion to launch these you
know huge central programs and so on and
so forth and because the x-men were the
ones that had basically saved the world
what ended up happening is the President
of the United States actually awarded
the Presidential Medal of Freedom to
Cyclops in response to this Captain
America basically said it's time for you
guys to come out to the world it's time
for you guys to say hey look we want to
be on a much grander stage the reason
why this is cool is because it leads to
Cyclops and Wolverine directly traveling
to the United Nations with a request
that all these different countries begin
dismantling their Sentinel program now
this is a pretty big deal because
remember but when it came to the mutant
population because there were so many up
before house of M they were scattered
everywhere I mean there were mutants all
over the place you had all these
different types of mutants out there in
the world their allegiances were
questionable sometimes their allegiances
were absolute but humanity didn't quite
know how to deal with them because there
were so many of them but with the
population being reduced down to 198
this is the equivalent of like a
cornered Fox right like a fox is most
dangerous when it's cornered humanity
views the x-men views mutants the same
way because there's so few of them
they're more dangerous now as they were
before because they're so consolidated
into a singular location now the other
half of this is remember that when it
comes to Marvel Comics mutants are by
and large the most powerful group Marvel
can say what they want to about the
Inhumans the mutants are the most
powerful you have mutants that range
everywhere from people with super
strength and agility all the way up to
people who can warp reality on a
universal scale so you have all manner
of extremely powerful characters and so
because of this humanity began to panic
but with Cyclops stepping up and saying
we are not enemies we are here to be
friends this is basically him trying to
sway humanity and assure them that they
are basically good guys the problem with
this is that in the middle of this
pledge with him trying to talk to you
know the United Nations
quinton choir ends up showing up now
Quinten choir was a character who had
really gained his claim to fame under
Grant Morrison where he basically
launched a revolution against like you
know Professor X in the Xavier Institute
but there are basically casualties in
his revolution the result is that kwitny
choir was basically taken under control
but as his character progressed because
he was so powerful in the sense that
he's an omega-level telepath Marvel
didn't really know what to do with this
character so eventually that is sort of
wrote him out of the story I wrote him
out of the landscape in the sense that
he evolved to a higher state of entropy
and basically reached a noncorporeal
form where he was just a form of energy
and then he was just bottled and that
was really it the crazy thing about this
is that with him showing up one of the
big ideas are Quentin choir under Grant
Morrison's run of new x-men is that he
wholeheartedly believed that magneto was
right that magneto was the right guy
that at the end of the day it was all
about the idea of basically forcing
humanity to accept mutants or enslaving
humanity that was basically the way it
was and so in response to this Quentin
choir basically says humans are not
these perfect beings and for them to sit
in judgment of the mutant kind and say
all man look at these mutants these bad
guys it really puts him in a sour spot
it runs right through him so what he
ends up doing is basically using his
telepathy to initiate this kind of
uncontrollable urge by all these humans
at the United Nations to start pouring
out their deepest darkest secrets and is
crazy because at the end of the day we
end up finding out that were the x-men
are shunned and people are just like oh
man the x-men are dangerous these normal
humans these members of the United
Nations are doing things like fixing
elections cheating on their wives
engaging in extortion money laundering
slave trading all these crazy different
things and so of course this eventually
leads to the to the question of will
anybody actually believe it but before
they end up getting into all that what
we end up finding out is that because
the x-men were arriving here at the very
least Cyclops and Wolverine humanity was
prepared what they ended up doing is the
engine of stockpiling sentinels that if
things popped off the Sentinels would
basically respond now when it comes to
Marvel Comics signals have been depicted
in different ways in truth the worst
sort of scenario with Sentinels was
depicted in like Days of Future past
right like where signals had basically
self-replicating each other and they had
evolved to the point where they could
encounter mutant abilities to a degree
and so of course this raising a question
why would humanity have weapons at a
peace conference but regardless of the
scenario Quinten choir ends up jumping
on camera and basically saying watch
what happens watch how these people will
basically go through and just start
making up lies and reasons for why it is
I said the things they did because of
this this is really Quintin choir saying
hey look no matter what happens here
they're all gonna make up lies and to a
degree it kind of makes sense right like
if you're a normal person sitting at
home and you hear about the dangerous
mutants well then suddenly it's very
easy for someone who is manipulated by
Quentin choir to come around and say
well I didn't say anything true that
telepath made me say those things and
then suddenly they haven't out this also
leads to the introduction of a kid by
the name of Cade Kilgore now Cade
Kilgore is probably one of my absolute
favorite villains in Marvel Comics
because he's like a little kid with no
powers he's just absolutely genius on
the crazy thing about this is that his
father is a weapons manufacturer and not
on the same level as Tony Stark it's
really more like firearms and different
things like that but because of the
panic that's going on with this whole
scenario at the UN being broadcast
across the world people are literally
just stockpiling firearms everywhere
they go and for the most part they're
buying
kilgore firearms well because of this
the stock value of the company just
skyrocketing into the air so on and so
forth but we end up finding out that
what Cead had actually done is blackmail
the board of directors of Kilgore of
industries whatever it's called in to
making Cade the CEO and then in turn
cage shoots his father and dumps him in
the mountains it's pretty extreme it's
pretty crazy but that's what this kid is
like that's the basis behind them he's
just that dark and he's just that cruel
but he's also that genius because what
he says is he's been planning this for
two years he's literally spent the last
two years just going through in planning
all these things in order to solidify
himself as one of the most capable
people out there now the other half of
this is a character by the name of Edie
and actually should be one of the
central points of this story at least I
think it's pronounced Edie it might be I
D I'm not a hundred percent sure but the
idea is that she was actually a
character that hailed from Nigerian she
has the ability to manipulate
temperature she's not like Iceman Edie
is more like pyro pyro can manipulate
fire the pyro cannot create fire with
Edie it's the exact same way if she's
sitting in a room that's extremely cold
she can't adjust the temperature of that
room unless she has heat to draw on from
some external source like an outside
hallway or something along those lines
it's really one of those ambiguous kind
of powers that Marvel just uses for
circumstance but she's gonna play a very
central role in this story which is
something that I want you to keep your
eyes on but the other thing about this
is that because of everything that had
gone on with Quentin choir instead of
humanity standing down on her Sentinel
program instead they're actually
doubling up what they end up doing is
they actually end up relaunching all
these sentinels that hadn't been seen
for quite some time under the idea that
they're trying to keep their country
safe and so because of this what we end
up finding out is at Cave kilgore by
virtue of his actions toppling his
father's company orchestrating this
whole scenario with Quentin choir by
basically releasing him and then
gambling on the idea that Quentin choir
would in turn show up at the United
Nations and try to broadcast some
message tantamount to what magneto would
have done that Kate Kilgore has been
inducted into the Hellfire Club now in
Marvel Comics the Hellfire Club is
actually a pretty cool organization they
are basically a group that exists behind
the scenes they serve the purpose of
influencing governments different things
like that the Hellfire Club originally
had people like Sebastian Shaw and Emma
Frost and so on and so forth but it was
largely people with powers the
implication that's being given here is
the Hellfire Club wasn't always that way
instead the Hellfire Club was just the
most influential people in the world
coming together to control things behind
the scenes not really for world
domination just to make sure that things
kind of ran according to their whims and
wants while the governments of the world
still remain intact the corporation's to
remain intact that kind of a thing but
what seems to be indicated here is that
the arrival of Sebastian Shaw the
arrival of Emma Frost these characters
taking up the roles of the black king
and the white queen respectively was
basically these people with powers
mutants effectively co-opting the
Hellfire Club and so this as far as the
Hellfire Club is concerned is it return
to the way things are supposed to be the
other half of this is that because a lot
of these sentinels that are being used
by these you know various governmental
organizations because they're so old as
soon as I started to fire them up they
immediately start falling apart they
immediately start breaking down and
going to pieces all over the place now
because the fact of what Quentin quire
did because he legitimately believed
that he was right what he ends up doing
is actually taking up residence with the
x-men he shows up at utopia and request
asylum and this is where the rift begins
to form between Cyclops and between
Wolverine now it's essentially the
ideology of Cyclops versus the ideology
of Wolverine remember Wolverine has been
both an Avenger and the x-men and his
loyalties for the most part are to the
x-men amande you really follow Cyclops
because in a lot of ways he agrees with
Cyclops as he's trying to carry out
Xavier c-can't in your dream of a
peaceful coexistence between humans and
mutants would exist with Xavier
currently being absent from the x-men
but cyclopses whole persona or his whole
belief system is rooted around the idea
that because there's so few mutants left
even if Quentin choir is the most wanted
fugitive in the world is the
responsibility of the x-men to hold him
accountable for what he did and to put
him on trial it's not the responsibility
of the rest of the world because in the
eyes of Cyclops if Quentin quieter were
to go on trial in front of the rest of
the world he would immediately be
convicted because it's literally
humanity trying a mutant what hope could
he possibly have at the same time the
x-men are basically trying to avoid a
conflict with the Avengers because when
Captain America calls up and says hey
man things are crazy out here you guys
have any idea what's going on with
Quentin choir if Cyclops were to speak
up and say yeah he's right over there
in America would immediately demand that
Quentin choir be handed over
if the x-men said no it would lead to a
conflict and so it's really just Cyclops
trying to figure out the best situation
now of course this also comes into the
idea of The Stepford cuckoos basically
chiming in and saying hey these
characters are here these characters are
over there we're responding to these
different emergencies so on and so forth
now the Stepford cuckoos are basically
cloned versions of Emma Frost is really
what it was because Emma Frost is one of
the most powerful telepaths in the world
the Weapon X project tried to duplicate
her abilities by cloning her the
difference between the Stepford cuckoos
and Emma Frost is that Emma Frost is
extremely powerful on her own and while
the Stepford cuckoos are capable
individually they're actually better
when they share a hive mind when the
three of them all work together the idea
is that with the Stepford cuckoos
working together the three of them are
almost as powerful as Emma Frost but the
idea here is that with this disagreement
between Wolverine and Cyclops Wolverine
is kind of takes off to a bar to drink
alcohol now the other half of this is
that within San Francisco the mayor's
actually launching the opening of a
Museum of mutant history now the reason
for this is because again because of the
fact that the x-men have helped to save
off the area's attacks against San
Francisco they actually gained the
support of the population this is
designed by the mayor to basically show
solace to say hey look some of us know
what you're about and some of us
appreciate what you do the problem with
this is that when Cyclops sends an x-men
team out there to basically you know
participate in the opening of this
mutant history it's more of a show of
force
as opposed to basically saying hey look
we're here to support the actions of the
mayor because the people Cyclops sends
are like magneto Iceman Namor the
Submariner Colossus and Emma Frost
these are powerhouses these are folks
who that you know if things pop off
don't quell whatever threat it is that
shows up and that's really what Cyclops
was looking to say he'd say hey look we
got five guys here and five people is
all we need to hold down a city the
problem with this is that Cyclops is not
accounting for Kade Kilgore then that's
why I killed more such a cool character
is because he thinks three four five
steps ahead and his mind as soon as this
in you know Museum of mutant history was
opened up and as soon as word reached
his ears that the x-men were going to
respond he immediately knew who it was
as Cyclops is going to send Cyclops was
gonna send his most powerful guys and so
Cade Kilgore had actually arranged
alongside other children who basically
killed
their own parents and usurp their
companies and launched an attack against
the x-men for the purpose of one
blocking the telepathy of Emma Frost and
to incapacitating these x-men that
Cyclops sent and so with all that's
really left is whatever x-men managed to
make their way over there which is
really just a B and then Wolverine who's
out at a bar watching everything pop off
and so as soon as things begin to go
awry the only two people who were there
that can actually do anything are
Wolverine who is on its way and et who's
watching everything unfold because of
this with Cyclops arriving on the scene
and do what he can to cope with the
situation as well as will rain showing
up what we end up having is this
conversation where et is watching
everything unfold Edie's question is
what should I do and this is what
creates the rift the idea of Cyclops is
do whatever you have to do to save the
lives of our fellow x-men the idea of
Wolverine is she's a kid she has no
business engaging in conflict like this
but edie ends up siding with Cyclops
uses her powers neutralizes the member
of the Hellfire Club manages to get some
of the x-men out the civilians are
largely saved but the members of the
Hellfire Club were all killed in the
explosion of the bomb now the biggest
reason why this is important is because
in the aftermath of this explosion is
actually a secondary detonation the
difference is that this secondary
detonation manipulates magnetism and
it's designed for the purpose of
literally being a program in and of
itself in the sense that it reaches out
and it grabs any and all forms of inner
metal and then it literally just forms
into a giant Sentinel now of course this
Sentinel just serves a purpose of trying
to get to utopia and then destroy the
mutants and that's really about it but
the biggest emphasis here is the fight
between Cyclops and the fight between
will ring because the idea here is that
for Wolverine himself Cyclops is that
nobody's talking about Cyclops is a guy
playing soldier but Cyclops has never
really fought in the fires of war like
he's never been in a war time conflict
he's fought a few characters here and
there he's fought the bad guys he's
fought some sentinels but when you're
Wolverine you fought in a civil war he
fought during world war one he fought
during world war two he fought to her
that he enough he fought through all
these different conflicts he seems so
many people lose their lives and he
seemed child soldiers and so because of
this when Cyclops began saying these
kids here are not kids they're x-men and
they need to be x-men in the mind of
Wolverine Cyclops is a lying himself
with the idea of using child soldiers
and for Wolverine this is intolerable
and so what he actually does is he laces
the place with 2,000 pounds of
explosives tells everybody to evacuate
utopia and then it just boils down to a
fight between himself and Cyclops now
this is cool because these guys they're
fighting for keeps these guys are out
for blood and it's kind of a cool
scenario because remember Wolverine the
the adamantium in his body that's that's
true adamantium
you can't like superheat it to the point
where it ends up just melting it doesn't
work that way once it hardens is
hardened for good so in truth Cyclops is
fighting a losing battle because
remember with his optic blasts they're
not heat they are basically concussion
blasts being hit with the optic beams of
Cyclops is like being punched and samely
hard it's not really overheating you
it's just hitting you with a massive
amount of energy at an extremely fast
pace so because of this it's literally
like trying to take out Wolverines
adamantium
with like a chisel it's not gonna work
but notice this I mean these guys are
bloody these guys are bruised Wolverines
missing half of his face but it's pretty
intense how far these guys are going now
of course once the signal arrives on the
scene you know it takes the combined
efforts of all the x-men to basically
destroy it and that's really about it
the whole signal gets destroyed Cait
Kilgore and company basically just kind
of bail out they watch the events unfold
and they seem to go completely unscathed
but the importance of this is that this
leaves Cyclops and it leaves will rain
with a bad taste towards one another at
the end of the day Wolverine has this
conversation with et where she basically
says well yeah I mean a bunch of those
hellfire guys died but I don't really
feel bad about it because it's just par
for the course of being an x-man but the
fact that she would give this answer the
fact that she would say well the x-men
are really more of like a militaristic
force as opposed to a peacekeeping force
means that the x-men have failed that
the dream of Charles Xavier is gone that
Cyclops is basically weaponized the
x-men those kids who are growing up in
the Autopia they're looking at this and
basically saying yeah like like we're
we're like an army and so when the eyes
of will reign Cyclops has lost his way
Cyclops is no longer a leader of the
x-men Cyclops is no longer a guy who can
effectively be someone to leave the team
proper and so what will rain ends up
doing is basically breaking off he forms
his own x-men team and actually what he
does is he goes back to the remains of
the Xavier school for gifted youngsters
with the intention of rebuilding it and
setting his own school up after that but
this is basically the rift this is where
things like Regenesis come into play
this is where if any of you guys have
been reading
expand within the last maybe six or
seven years this is where you run into
the scenario of there being like a
cyclops school and a Wolverine school
this is why that happened is because the
events of schism and the fact that there
are irreconcilable differences between
Wolverine and Cyclops Bowe that being
said guys we're gonna go ahead and bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like oh the cool
thing about this to you something else
is that because of the fact that there
are two different schools Marvel
launched two different titles what they
ended up doing is they created this
story called Regenesis which is just a
one-shot and it's basically the
aftermath of schism and then Wolverines
team has followed in Wolverine in the
x-men and then of course cyclopses team
has followed in uncanny x-men they
actually relaunch uncanny x-men with
issue number one which is kind of cool
but anyway guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]